[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  you know we're a free nation this is  exactly why the jewish people came here  to establish their own  uh national state  [Applause]  this is the image that these far right  ultra nationalists want you  to see flying the israeli flag in the  heart  of occupied east jerusalem it's hugely  provocative  for the palestinians but what some have  told us that there is a small victory  here the fact that for the first time  they're not being allowed to march  through damascus gate and through the  muslim quarter  this march is beyond provocation it's a  dictation of occupation  the only legitimate flag here in babylon  in jerusalem is the palestinian flag  the israeli flag here is an occupation  symbol and occupation flag  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you